はいみなさんこんにちは同源ですと今日は最も効果的な日本語の勉強方法について話し
てみたいと思います今日は友達の会 jason を選んでいますので
頭が呼ばれるですね今日だから日本語で言って
に切っはいうジョブ店です add to do が最も効果的な勉強方法だから
ティっんじゃないから自己紹介をお願いします
はいじゃあ j と申します30歳ですアティペットあっあそこ日本語で言っていっ
って噂はデマしそう
そうだけど今日のポイントは常に日本語で話すこと
クリス良いです当然ダウンもう
最も効果的な日本語勉強方法だからそうだけどでやっぱ変だはそんな感じ
その最も効果的な学習方法勉強方法についてなんですが常に日本語を使おう
ことです映画とかを見るときは字幕とかを使って日本語の吹き替えばを見たりとか
まあもしくはパソコンの設定とかも日本語にして日本語
なんか日本語にしで中う
わかりましたお母さんじゃあ日本で何をしてるんですか僕は今ゲーム会社で働きます
はいえーそこで具体的に何をしてるんですか
敗北はんで
voodoo
先月が開発者ホラー英語しゃべったじゃん
あいやーっとからそれはジェイソンが外国編だから猛追
いよいよサークルジェイソンはこの漢字の読み方わかりますか
じゃ pc ボード me the 感じ面スター
コーヒーですジェイソンの日本の好きな場所はどこですか
10月米グリーティングシーターいうタイムへ嘘です
僕たちは日本語でしゃべってました僕はいつも日本語で喋って0号でした
ボクは常に日本語でしゃべってます最も効果的な勉強方法だからこの
満点とってみせますへとい
区の東北0 bd でしょ
チェーン
ni